Mare is a sergeant detective
living in a community
in Pennsylvania.
MARE SHEEHAN: If you got
something you wanna tell me,
you better do it now
'cause I'm gonna start digging
through your life,
and I'm gonna find out
everything.
And if you're lying to me, it's
going to be very bad for you.
KATE WINSLET:
There's an unsolved crime
within the community,
so all eyes have been on Mare
because it's fallen to her,
and she so far has failed.
BRAD INGELSBY: The community's
labeled her a hero,
but she never felt like a hero.
There's a constant conflict
in Mare
of trying to uphold this image,
even though she knows
in her heart it's crumbling.
COLIN ZABEL: I'm just here
to help you find out
what happened
to those two girls.
Given your relationships
here in town,
it couldn't have been easy
on you.
She deals with a lot.
She carries
enormous personal grief.
We do come to understand
why she is the way she is
and why she's had to make
herself that strong
with that kind of
coarse exterior.
And it's all a coping mechanism.
She's just an everyday woman
coping with an enormous amount.
SPEAKER:
Can I ask if you're seeing
anyone now? Just to talk.
It's been my experience
that it helps parents
-who've lost children-
-No. No, I never... um...
CRAIG ZOBEL: Mare's journey
on the show involves struggles,
and the fact that she lost
her son to suicide
and that she has to move on
from that
in order to really grow
and be able to be
the detective
that the community needs.
WINSLET: I loved how vulnerable
/
and strong at the same time
Mare truly is.
She's this extraordinary
dichotomy
of both of those things,
and that sense of her
really being entrenched
in the community.
(GUNSHOTS)
I really did find myself
becoming incredibly immersed
in this character, largely
because of the fine details
I had to know because
any sergeant detective
investigating a community murder
would've had to know
those things too.
INGELSBY: She's just
a persistent detective.
She cares about these people.
I mean, she doesn't admit it.
There's a level of emotion
connected to these girls
that makes it personal,
and she wants to figure out
what happened.
WINSLET:
We cheer for her along the way,
and that's what I hope people
can identify with the most
is that she handles everyone
with a great deal of compassion
and understanding,
but at the same time,
she's kind of firm but fair.
She's just
so remarkably capable,
stoic, brave woman who's dealing
with all the elements
of family life and struggle
and grief
and trying to do her best
as a mother,
as a young grandmother,
and as a woman in a community
that look to her
so often for answers.